Nisha was a devastating critic of,
I would say dogmatic Christianity,
Christianity as it was instantiated in institutions,
I suppose.
Although he,
he's a very paradoxical thinker because for example,
one of the things neat just said was that he didn't believe that the scientific
revolution would have ever got off the ground if it hadn't been for Christianity
and more specifically for Catholicism because he believed that over the course
of really a thousand years,
the European mind,
so to speak,
had to train itself to interpret everything that was known within a single
coherent framework,
coherent if you accept the initial axioms,
a single coherent framework and so neat,
you believe that that Catholicism Nation of,
of,
of the phenomena of life and of history produced the kind of mine that was then
capable of transcending that it's dogmatic foundations and then concentrating on
something else,
which in this particular case happened to be the natural world.
And so Nietzsche,
you believe that in some sense Christianity died at its own hand.
It had spent a very long period of time trying to attune people to the necessity
of the truth.
You know,
absent the corruption and all of that,
that's always part of any human endeavor.
And then the truth,
the spirit of the truth that was developed by Christianity turned on the roots
of Christianity.
And everyone woke up and said something like,
or thought something like,
well how is it that we came to believe any of this?
Um,
it's like waking up one day and noting,
noting that you really don't know why you put a Christmas tree up,
but you've been doing it for a long time.
And that's what people do.
And in know,
there are reasons that Christmas trees came about,
but the,
what would you say?
The ritual lasts long after the reasons have been forgotten.
So now Nicha although he was a critic of Christianity and also a champion of,
of its disciplinary capacity,
because you see,
the other thing that needs you believed was that it was not possible to be free
in some sense,
unless you,
unless you had been a slave.
And,
and by that he meant that you don't go from childhood to full fledged adult
individuality.
You go from childhood to a state of discipline,
which you might think is akin to slavery,
to self imposed slavery,
that that would be the best scenario where you have to discipline yourself to
become something specific before you might be able to retain the generality that
you had as a child.
And he believed that Christianity had played that role for Western civilization.
Um,
bought in the late 18 hundreds,
he announced that God was dead.
And you often hear of that as something triumphant.
But for Nietzsche it wasn't because he was too nuanced.
The thinker to be that simple minded,
see,
neat.
Yep.
Understood that this is something I'm going to try to make clear as that
we,
there's,
there's a very large amount that we don't know about the structure of experience
that we don't know about reality and we have our articulated representations of
the world.
And then you can think of outside of that,
there are things we know absolutely nothing about and there's a buffer between
them.
And those are the things we sort of know something about and we don't know them
in an articulated way.
Here's an example.
You know,
sometimes you're arguing with one of your,
someone close to you and they're in a bad mood,
you know,
and uh,
they're being touchy and unreasonable and you keep the conversation up and maybe
all of a sudden they,
you know,
they get angry.
Maybe they cry and then when they cry they figure out what they're angry about.
And it has nothing to do with you even though you might've been.
What precipitated the argument?
You know,
one that's an interesting phenomena as far as I'm concerned because it means
that people can know things at one level without being able to speak what they
know at another.
And so in some sense,
the thoughts rise up from the body and they do that in moods and they do that in
images and they do that and actions.
And we have all sorts of ways that we understand before we understand in a fully
articulated manner.
And so we have this articulated space that we can all discuss.
And then outside of that,
we have something that's more akin to a dream that we're embedded in.
And it's an emotional dream that we're embedded in.
And that's based at least in part on her actions.
I'll describe that later.
And then outside of that is what we don't know anything about at all.
And in that dream,
that's where the mystics live and that's where the artists live and they're a
mediators between the absolute unknown and the things we know for sure.
And
you see
what that means in some sense is what we know is established on a form of
knowledge that we don't really understand and that if those two things are out
of sync,
so you might say if our articulated knowledge is out of sync with our dream,
then we become dissociated internally.
We think things we don't act out and we act out things we don't dream and that
produces a kind of sickness of the spirit and and that sickness of the spirit it
see it.
It's cure is something like an integrated system of belief and representation.
And then people turn to things like ideologies,
which I regardless parasites on an underlying religious substructure to try to
organize their thinking and then that's a catastrophe.
And that's what Nisha,
Nisha foresaw.
You see?
He knew that when we knocked the slats out of the base of Western civilization
by destroying this representation,
this is God ideal,
let's say,
that we would destabilize and move back and forth.
They,
between nihilism,
let's say in the extremes of videology,
he was particularly concerned about radical left ideology and no one believed in
it and predicted this in the late 18 hundreds which is really an absolute
intellectual tour.
De Force of staggering magnitude predicted that in the 20th century that
hundreds of millions of people would die because of the replacement of these
underlying dreamlike structures with this rational,
rational,
but deeply incorrect representation of the world.
And you know,
we've been oscillating back and forth between the left and right in some sense
ever since.
And you know,
with some good sprinkling of nihilism in there and despair,
some sense that's the situation of the modern western person in increasingly of
people in general.